welcome back to SEO foundations in this
video we're going to cover on-page
optimization at the end of this lesson
you will be able to describe the two
broad categories of ranking signals
recite best practices for on-page
signals such as title tags header tags
URLs alt text and others identify
on-page SEO practices that you should
avoid and finally describe how natural
language processing aims to understand
the meaning behind the text on page
optimisation as the name suggests is the
practice of optimizing webpages to rank
higher and get relevant traffic from the
search engine on page optimization
includes both content and HTML source
code optimization search engine
optimization can be very complex so when
you're trying to understand it for the
first time I find it very easy just to
break it up into general concepts that
you might already have an understanding
of when you look at the hundreds of
signals that go into SEO they can be
broken up into either relevancy or
because sometimes it's both popularity
so relevancy and popularity out of all
these signals they fit into one of these
two things we're going to break all the
signals we have into these two areas in
this section we're going to talk about
the on-page factors that's because these
are the factors that you have direct
impact upon and you can make a small
tweak and have a big impact with organic
traffic with your on-page relevancy
factors the primary on-page relevancy
factors that I'll cover in this lesson
are title tags and meta descriptions
header tags which are used for headlines
and subheadings website URLs and URL
structure image alt text internal links
keyword usage and sitemaps let's start
with one of my favorites and that is the
title tag this is also called a page
title the page title is not shown on the
page now rather it is displayed on the
brow
or tab and this is what makes it highly
important is that in addition to being
displayed on the browser tab it is also
the title tag or the page title that is
shown on the text in the Google search
results as the link to the page the page
title influences both the click-through
rates and people's first impressions of
our website next up we have the Meta
Description
now the Meta Description can be a bit
confusing the Meta Description is in the
code and it does not influence rankings
but it does influence clicks people will
see your snippet or your page
information in the search engine results
that gray text is the Meta Description
if you don't have a Meta Description
then it may pull information from the
page you can affect this and improve the
chances of your Meta Description
appearing if you write a short
descriptive phrase of the content or the
purpose of the page and just because we
edit these elements does not guarantee
that they will show up I often say that
we affect the change but we cannot
control it this is because the search
engine may override your changes and
show different content in these areas
sometimes it may help and it might be a
better description but many times it's
not now let's go to the next element the
header tags these are also referred to
as the heading and subheading and this
is how HTML was built when the web was
first created it enables a logical
hierarchy of content so starting with
the headline then displaying a
subheading and then subheadings after
that the idea here is that you're
establishing a hierarchy of information
so you start with the h1 like a
newspaper there's only one main headline
per page it describes the main purpose
of the page then a subheading the h2
this is how you break the sub content
into subcategories
korie's obviously you'll want to use a
keyword in there as well you see by
describing the purpose of the page in
the headline and then again in a
subheading you're naturally going to use
your primary and secondary keywords
because you're going to associate them
with the product or the purpose and the
benefit the key is to keep it short you
see after the headline are the
subcategories the h2s and then your h3
is typically used as a paragraph heading
now putting the keyword and these
headings alone does not make your page
optimized remember the purpose is to
provide a quick reference for people to
find the content they need within
seconds so short explanatory heading and
subheadings paragraph headings are very
effective and naturally you'll be using
keywords to help people locate the
information that is most important to
them now if we go back to the search
engine results page the SERP there is
another element in that listing the page
title is the large blue text the Meta
Description is the grey text now the
green text is the URL of the page that
is listed this is the address of the
page just like the address for your home
the Internet knows that the URL is the
address for that page this is extremely
important for SEO for a variety of
reasons the most important though is
your keyword usage I like to make sure
that I have at least one relevant word
in the URL now also here keep it short
one of the worst things you can do is
have a URL full of keywords or even
worse - ate them all
remember people use these URLs they
provide context for the page people also
copy and paste URLs into mobile messages
emails and social links so it is
extremely important to keep these short
succinct and I like to say readable now
I've just briefly touched about the
importance of the URL and now let's look
at the URL structure first let's start
with the primary core of the URL the
domain name in the
example with the URL I have here
example.com that's the domain name so
this is the first thing that people see
with your online business now beyond the
Internet this is going to be what's in
all of your ads emails brochures
business cards and online your social
profiles all of your marketing efforts
are going to drive people to this domain
there's a lot of advice about buying or
using domains that have your keywords in
them and unfortunately domains have been
being sold for decades so there's less
chance of finding a domain with the
keywords you want now the search engines
don't make the keyword used in the
domain a primary ranking signal so
that's good
however the domain is your business it
needs to be memorable if you have a very
I call it a spammy looking domain name
with multiple words and hyphens or one
that's hard to spell or confusing people
are going to make an initial impression
off of that so make sure you have
something that's going to make a great
first impression
here's the rule for a domain name
something that's easy to spell and easy
to pronounce
ideally sure it's something you can type
and share something you're going to be
able to put on a business card and be
proud of not something that you bought
primarily because you want it for SEO
reasons and you think with that you're
going to succeed as an example just
think about Amazon their domain name
says nothing about books and yet it grew
to be one of the largest e-commerce
companies in the world the same with
Alibaba or Google their domain names
we're not the keyword but their
marketing and branding built their
company now everything after the domain
is a subdirectory this is based on your
website organization as an example if
you have a website selling shoes then
the subdirectory can be called shoes
it's easy right the subdirectory is the
folder that contains the relevant files
or pages for that group think of a file
folder with documents inside the file
folder is usually based on a major
category of content or products now
inside the folder are individual
documents or pages these files or pages
usually come after the subdirectory in
this example you see the file dot HTML
the next step in optimizing the URL is
to name the page in a way that explains
the content of the page to use our
e-commerce shoe website a page name
would usually be a specific product name
this way you would end up with domain
name forward slash shoes as the category
forward slash brand name running shoe
insert that here if you've ever looked
at the HTML that make up the
instructions of the page you'll
understand a bit more of how search
engines get the information from the
page the text on the page in the markup
such as the headings provide
instructions as to where the text is
located the importance and prominence of
the text in addition to the arrangement
of the overall page HTML is a set of
instructions for a browser to assemble
the page and the search engines use that
as well now search engines spiders
cannot see images as the internet
developed many attributes were added to
provide for accessibility and additional
features users that are sight impaired
cannot see images
and the alternative text tag describes
the image further there are many times
when our bandwidth is it strong and not
all of the images will load in that case
we need the alt text description to
provide the context of the image and its
purpose search engines use this alt text
description to gain additional context
about the page the content of the image
and its purpose now we have an entire
section on links but at this point I
just want to cover internal links an
internal link is a link from one page on
your website to another page of your own
website now this is important from a
relevancy perspective you'll see
internal links in your main navigation
you'll likely have a link that says home
one that says contact us or about our
company what you're showing two search
engines and two humans is that this
section if you click on this link is
about our company or this is where you
find our contact information
you see these links are not votes like
external links however they provide
relevance and context to the information
on your own website
let's dive in a little more on keywords
when a search engine crawls and
processes your website it doesn't simply
look for the instances of specific
keywords it's a lot more complex than
that it's using a technology called
natural language processing natural
language processing uses algorithms to
try to understand the meaning of text
you see search engine processing is
attempting to be human this is the same
way that people see and hear the words
and we're using the words to find the
meaning expressed in the words similarly
when a search engine goes to your
website that may see key words but it's
looking for the context of those words
you may say football but just having the
word football repeated throughout your
website isn't going to help you rank
specifically for football what you need
to do and what is more common in actual
human conversation
happens very naturally when we talk
about football we use naturally
additional words such as goal and
referee and World Cup you see Google and
the other search engines are going to
take these into account by usage of
other synonyms and other common words
you present the context of a bigger
broader idea for your website the next
site signal that we have is sitemaps now
there are two kinds of sitemaps
there's the sitemap that is for humans
and there is the sitemap that are for
search engine robots crawlers or spiders
the one that is for human is called an
HTML sitemap you've probably seen these
before the link is generally in the
footer of a website if you click on it
it shows you the major sections of the
website provides some search
functionality but looking at it as a
human it shows you the hierarchy of the
website and weird to find important
information it shows how everything fits
together now there's something else that
exists called an XML sitemap it's not
linked from any page of your website but
exists as an independent file on your
server now this is something you can see
but it is formatted for search engine
spiders using a programming language
called XML
it shows the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs of the website every
page every document every image and it
also shows the date that each page was
last updated or changed so at this point
we've covered a lot of things that are
important and things that you should be
doing when optimizing your on-page
content now let's go a different
direction and cover things that you
should not be doing keyword stuffing
hidden text repetitive anchor text and
cloaking the first one is keyword
stuffing now back in the early days of
search engine optimization people used
to increase the instances of words on
the page now this is well before natural
language processing at that time search
engines were looking for occurrences of
specific words well search and
they're very smart about this what may
have worked 20 years ago or 10 years ago
keyword stuffing does not work you're
not going to rank better for any given
phrase by including it a dozen or more
times on the page in fact you might get
an over optimization penalty by
constantly repeating the same word over
and over focus on writing content that
engages with your visitors and uses
language naturally now the next one is
hidden text unfortunately I still see
this this is when you write content that
is solely for search engines and not for
people now typically it is attempted by
writing a lot of repetitive keywords as
text coloring it white and placing it
against a white background you see this
was developed as another way to add more
keywords stuff text without the user
seeing the overuse of keywords now it
didn't work too well in the past and it
definitely does not work today
this tactic backfires in two ways first
search engines can tell when it's white
text on a white background
it's easy to tell from a computer
science point of view search engines
read the HTML and in the HTML are the
instructions for colors when you hide
text modern search engines are smart
enough to figure it out probably better
than a human now secondly it's done to
hide repetitive keyword stuff text which
is the second thing against you these
outdated unprofessional tactics will
most likely get a website penalized by
the search engines the next one is
repetitive anchor text you may have
followed a link to a page when looking
for a business or information and
instead of the information you want and
you get a page that doesn't feel like it
was written for people every sentence is
redundant repetitive and almost every
keyword is linked even when there
doesn't need to be a link it confuses
the flow of the information on the page
now again this used to be a tactic that
sometimes would work but it's no longer
helpful search engines and their natural
language processing algorithms have
advanced significantly they can tell
when something's not readable when
something is
probably intended for machines and
rankings but not for people search
engines will figure it out
please don't waste time on redundant
links trying to inflate the relevance of
your links and pages the last thing to
cover here is cloaking cloaking is the
idea of showing one thing to the search
engines and something entirely different
to humans now this is related to the
rest of the tactics I just covered it's
something that used to work but it was
expressly against the search engine
guidelines well it may have worked if
the search engine is discovered it on
your website you could have been
penalized or dropped from the search
engine results entirely now we've
covered all of the most important
on-page optimization factors let's take
a look at what the theoretically
perfectly optimized page would look like
in this example we can see many of these
elements being used together you can
also see that the base key phrase
digital camera is being repeated but
always included with a specific context
first at the top of the page the URL
which has digital cameras in the address
the page title follows using the context
of the information and adding the word
reviews you can also see at the top of
the page that the main navigation and
secondary navigation also called the
breadcrumb navigation provides context
of the pages location within the entire
website and natural keyword usage the h1
headline is the key phrase but also
happens to simply be the best title for
the content of the page
the subsequent subheadings provide
additional information such as ratings
recommendations and features the links
provide relevant ways to access
additional content the image utilizes
alt text
there are also clear calls to action
which provide relevant offers to
visitors as you can see the context of
all of the content is very strong and
sends a clear relevancy signal to both
search engines and readers to conclude
this section I'd like to cover the top
influencing factors now sometimes you
may find these as lists but I found
a bit more practical to separate them
into categories typically every year
you'll find these collections of lists
from surveys experts or speculation some
are from testing but honestly you can't
ever truly test a search engine as they
change a little bit with every algorithm
so the best thing is to take from these
lists these factors that are the tried
and true factors over the years that
have worked consistently also those
tactics that not only make your website
more effective with users they tend to
do well with search engines so if a
tactic serves that dual purpose it's a
good tactic so these are not exclusive
and have two lists for every situation
but guides and indicators for you to use
the top on-page factors from surveys
opinions and data are these a relevant
page title page headings anchor text
links a keyword based URL a key word or
contextual file name such as page name
image name or PDF file name alt text in
images and finally what you do with the
content on a page to make it more
readable lists bullet points and bolded
text the top factors for off page
linking tend to contain these items the
total number of domains linking to you
the number of highly influential domains
linking to you the number of unique
domain IP addresses the total backlinks
without nofollow limits the total
relevant anchor text in links to you and
finally the types and context of
keywords in anchor text links the domain
also contributes factors to your overall
rankings such as the age of the domain
which would include ownership
information such as the length of time
owned and operated by a company the real
business information tied to that domain
such as the business address being the
same as the business registration
address for the domain
in addition the signals from social
accounts driving visits to the domain
functionally the search engines also
utilize some attribution based on the
quality of programming of the website
for instance taking care of the basic
search engine protocols of the
robots.txt file XML sitemap and HTTP
protocol websites that implement these
features have shown that they are
familiar with search engine guidelines
and protocol now one of the changes over
the past few years has been the
implementation of PageSpeed as an
increasing ranking factor slow loading
pages with a lot of extraneous code that
slow the delivery of the page will be
penalized as they take away from the
user experience optimizing the page code
speeding up the load time of the page
can directly impact your rankings and
this is closely related to the mobile
friendliness of your website if your
website is not mobile friendly it will
be limited in visibility as Google's
primary index is focused on mobile
devices and mobile delivery behavioral
factors are the newest factors and with
the advent of artificial intelligence it
is making determining the intent and the
is making determining easier for a
search engine to derive a judgement of
relevancy based on interaction while the
extent of these signals is not fully
known it is suspected that they are
minor but growing in importance these
include the amount of users that search
for a brand name businesses name and go
to that result showing brand awareness
also the amount of direct visits
bypassing search time on page pages per
session which is also called the depth
of visit and lastly the behavior of a
searcher from the results page how many
results are clicked how many times do
they return to the results this
evaluation is looking to judge if the
results presented were satisfactory or
efficient for that query the two broad
categories of ranking signals are
popularity and relevance of the on-page
factors the page title is the most
important individual field the URL is
important and should be memorable alt
text is important for search engines as
well as for site impaired humans avoid
keyword stuffing hidden text repetitive
anchor text and cloaking natural
language processing is a technology that
aims to understand the intent that
humans have when searching for
information hi there if you liked this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here